okay
oh as many of you guys know i happen to
be bros
with mike tyson i was on his podcast
we're in the house like not even a
second and he says you got any coke
and i said [ __ ] yeah i do and he was on
my podcast
mike tyson steve i wasn't thankful
of together if you saw my gnarly special
you watched him break my nose
and all this crazy stuff but in any case
mike came out of retirement in this
exhibition match
against roy jones jr at the staples
center in los
angeles under strict coveted protocol
so mike's business partner invited a
bunch of mike's friends
to watch the fights at the tyson ranch
and i
already knew how cool that place was
because when mike did my podcast
we drove the rv right into the property
and i was excited because i only wanted
to do two things that night
watch some fights and get totally laid
so lux and i showed up at the tyson
ranch
all i gotta do is open my mouth and you
do know who i am huh
and in order to get into this party
every single person had to be coveted
tested
us included are you gonna be mad if i
smoke weed
go for it do it this is the place to do
it i mean i smelt it and i was like
if i was diabetic i wouldn't be mad at
you for having sugar honey
smoke
so i've got the masks because we are
clean
it was totally catered they had all this
great stuff going on
[Applause]
and it was like a who's who of my
favorite ufc fighters
luke rockhold fabrice over doom
and kelvin gastelum who got the ufc
fight of the year last year and here at
this party
luke rockhold and kelvin gaston jump in
the ring and start sparring
plus you got jeremy piven the guy who
played urkel
and stevo and if that's not the mount
rushmore of
a-list celebrities i don't know what it
is
and then the fight started
i gotta say mike looked fantastic fights
ended we all cheered
[Applause]
and i was like looks like i watched some
fights
now i'm gonna get totally laid
so lux and i retreated into the rv made
up the bed
and yeah i took her to pound town an
epic ending to an epic night thanks all
of you for watching
now we're going on a real wild ride
it's a wild ride baby come on
and i just want to say thanks to mike
tyson for always being so good to me
and for letting me say the things i said
and
put the stuff out there that i put in
that gnarly special
if you haven't seen it check it out
stevo.com
here's a trailer get ready this is going
to be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready yeah
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
they're not gonna hurt me you're gonna
piss me off